I was surprised to learn that gpt4 slash
chat GPT open ai's amazing assistant was
only trained on text information yet it
somehow still learned to see and to draw
to that was amazing but today it gets
even better it actually learned to see
and hear and speak at the same time wow
so how does this work well let's ask it
to help us lower our bike seat and find
out that should be easy right
here I was thinking wait a minute why
does this need an image he's writing the
text question not enough well look here
are the instructions uh-huh step number
one we need to locate the lever or a
bolt now we can post an image mark it
and ask is this deliver it says Nope
that is a bolt and then it tells us we
would need to loosen it that is cool but
not mind-blowing cool yet and now comes
the magic you know what little AI here
is the manual how about you read it and
here is the toolbox please help we don't
even know if we have the required tool
so do we
look at that yes we have the required
tool and not only that but I love the
fact that it even tells us exactly where
it is and Bam we are done excellent we
can even celebrate together with this
little AI now let's get it to talk with
the new Dolly 3 text to image system we
can now create adorable little imaginary
animals like the amazing Larry and even
illustrate their lives and we will now
be able to ask Chan GPT to not only
create but also narrate a bedtime story
here goes once in a tranquil Woodland
there was a fluffy mama cat named Lyla
one sunny day she cuddled with her
playful kitten Milo under the shade of
an old oak tree and we can also ask for
recipes poems and explanations as well
and I found something amazing here
listen
in a pocket or under a tree oh where
could my little Keys be I checked in the
fridge behind the TV even the cat looked
up as if to plea they jingle they jangle
they opened the door yet they always end
up on a different floor did you notice I
think it is reading this not as a simple
continuous text but it reads it as a
poem should be read I love it already
the included paper slash System card
reveals that safety considerations which
is highly appreciated as we know a
little more about the inner workings of
the technique not a full paper yet but
more information on when and how it
should or should not be giving out
medical information because sometimes it
is a bit inconsistent and now it tries
to resist jailbreak attempts where users
try to fool it into doing unsavory
things so when do we get to use this
this is coming to GPT plus and
Enterprise users and it is possible that
these features are already online by the
time you see this video but at most two
weeks from now according to open AI but
let's stop for a moment and appreciate
how absolutely incredible it is that we
are now here why well here on two minute
papers we talked about gpt2 10 gpt's
predecessor before yes such a thing
existed and not even that long ago four
years ago in 2019 then it could generate
text and would be able to answer
questions and the fellow scholar with a
Keen Eye noticed that things were
starting to take off this is an
absolutely miraculous graph look as we
grew the neural network it slowly
started closing in on human level
reading comprehension then for gpt3 just
a year later in 2020 I said that it was
good at almost everything math excellent
good but it could already code app
websites create graphs help us create a
population report and oh look at that
reading comprehension just kept on
increasing and increasing up to nearly
the level of humans then in 2023 gpt4
appeared this was a historic paper
what is this yes you are seeing
correctly this is the USA biology
Olympiad exam this needs Next Level
capabilities and a little help too
because otherwise it would require
visually inspecting and evaluating
electrocardiograms so it got a little
help in the form of a text description
so how correct was it what are you
kidding
99th percentile better than almost all
humans and now we can use it as an
assistant and it can actually see and
hear and speak and all this progress
from gpt2 in just four years and a
couple papers it almost feels like we
are living in a science fiction world
what a time to be alive and you all saw
this history on two minute papers with
Dr Carol Jonah and if you would like to
see how this amazing story unfolds in
the future make sure to subscribe and
hit the Bell icon to not miss out on it
weights and biases provides tools to
track your experiments in your deep
learning projects their system is
designed to save you a ton of time and
money and it is actively used in
projects at prestigious Labs such as
open AI Toyota research GitHub and more
and the best part is that weights and
biases is free for all individuals
academics and open source projects it
really is as good as it gets make sure
to visit them through
wnb.me 2mp or just click the link in the
video description and you can get a free
demo today our thanks to weights and
biases for helping us make better videos
for you